here with reaction Fox News contributor
Newt Gingrich all right Newt um I've
never watched Ted lasso but I guess they
thought it was important uh to put them
up at the in the White House Press Room
uh any thoughts on that one
well first of all mental health is a
very important issue and the number of
Americans who are committing suicide or
dying from drug overdose or having their
lives ruined running up homeless that's
all a tragedy but I think what today
showed you more was the absolute shallow
behavior of the Biden Administration we
are in a very dangerous situation we
have two our two major International
competitors Russia and China coming
closer and closer together we have a
president who clearly does not have a
clue what to do we have a vice president
who was an embarrassment and the best
possible insurance policy for keeping
Biden as president
and Americans need to understand this is
not a game this is not one of those
things you get on Xbox we're in a real
world faced with real crises and we have
a president who is totally out of touch
with reality in terms of what's going on
in the world I I personally as a
historian I think that this is the most
dangerous period we've been in since
Washington crossed to Delaware on
Christmas night 1776 I think the number
of things going bad are so great
and the threat to our civilization is so
great that we really need a dramatic
change and you saw today
you know not only is
the show a situation comedy but in large
part the Biden Administration is a
situation comedy and that's dangerous
because the world is not a comedy well
and and the the saddest part about all
this is that apparently when you know
when Putin signed a and no limits
partnership with z uh the Xi Jinping
last year or shortly before he attacked
in the Ukraine and now within a few days
of Putin being called a you know a war
criminal by an international Court Xi
Jinping shows up to kind of give him
diplomatic cover it is a uh it is a
dangerous time in that regard but the
United States is now in a I think an
untenable position because as we give
arms to Ukraine you know we really don't
give them enough to win but just enough
to keep fighting am I wrong
that's no I look I think you're right I
think first of all uh it's very sobering
that uh Xi Jinping last week Secretary
General of the Chinese Communist party
which is his real title
um gave four different speeches in one
week on preparing for war
and I think people should take that
seriously and understand how determined
how aggressive and how competent Xi
Jinping is Putin of course was a KGB
agent and is himself ruthless tough
smart so you've got two people who are
sort of gangster allies and they
represent the competitive alternative
they are presented to totalitarian
dictatorship-led world where they take
care of each other against the
democracies almost exactly a recreation
of the Axis powers of Italy Germany and
Japan in the 1930s who took on the
democracies and now unlike the 1930s we
have a president dedicated to weakness
dedicated to confusion uh whose family
you just saw this last week got three
million dollars exactly from the Chinese
Communists in one check
there's lots of other money out there we
have no idea how corrupted the Biden
family is but what we do know is that
with a attorney general who is as bitter
and as frankly dishonest as the current
attorney general nothing is going to be
done and that's a crisis in itself you
have an American System an enormous
crisis with a news media that doesn't
want to cover the truth well and and
finally just a final question with our
reaction to the spycraft and letting it
float across the United States uh you
know Xi Jinping has already tested us
and I think we failed the test
look I think Xi Jinping looks at the
Biden family which I suspect he thinks
he owns right and he thinks this is the
moment when America truly is what Mao
Zedong which called us a paper tiger and
I think it's a very sobering and frankly
as a citizen a very frightening moment
in American history well Newt Gingrich
thank you very much we're very lucky to
have you God bless hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else